let me pull up this uh this tweet here
uh that's what I tweeted Google is
trying to get YouTubers to Lobby on
their behalf to protect the current
iteration of section 230. you'll start
to notice videos and social posts
defending it these are not organic I
have another call with Google about it
today that was 12 hours ago and then I
posted at about 5 PM Google
unfortunately canceled my call with them
section 230 is vital to a free and open
internet but big Tech should not be free
to editorialize and be immune at the
same time
so basically what's happened is it is
Gonzalez V Google I I could be getting
it wrong but my understanding is that
YouTube had recommended Terror videos or
something to somebody because it's
automatic right and then they said up
that you provided support to them by by
giving them access to the system or
something that effect or people were
able to search for it and find it and so
you are choosing to recommend it and now
with the Supreme Court granting
um cert whatever the full word is
they're actually going to be hearing
this case and and YouTube's freaking out
I think the reason the guy I think the
reason they got canceled on me is
because I kind of went off on them I
wish I could hear that conversation but
but the issue is basically that YouTube
is saying no you can't hold us
responsible for what people say which is
the platform
that bans anyone who says things we
don't like and then chooses to highlight
the things we like specifically that's
insane yeah featuring featuring is like
an inherent uh publishing uh tactic and
I think like when it was originally
obviously when it was conceived
um the internet was smaller and
everything
um but I think it was given in good
faith too that they would actually take
action against you know illegal content
because obviously they they knew that
you know they couldn't control
everything that was on the internet at
once and that's why they had a liability
protections is because you know say on
Twitter like thousands of users are
posting every day uh they can't catch
everything in real time but that's the
thing I believe they gave it to him in
good faith that they would Target you
know the like I was bringing up earlier
the illegal content the most important
and like harmful content rather than the
EU worried about misinformation or uh
hate speech or whatever they want to say
um that they're going after right now so
I read I read a story about New York
that uh some of you may have heard me
reference before when they when they
banned public drinking there was a like
a city council member or something who
said
let this law not ever be misconstrued to
say that a man can't enjoy a beer with
his lunch it was specifically about
drunkards strolling about causing
problems well now you can't enjoy a beer
with lunch because the law gets written
and then everyone says oh that's what it
says so you take a look at what happens
with the law in section 230 they're like
hey you can't be held responsible if
someone else posts something and then
they go yeah but can we take stuff up
take stuff down they're like well no
because then you're editorializing yeah
yeah but hold on man like what if
someone posts something illegal I gotta
take it down right oh good point okay so
if you're taking if you're taking things
down that are obscene lewd or or illegal
then you you can take it down and can't
be considered a publisher of content if
you're choosing and they went okay so
now we're going to ban conservatives
that's where we're at yeah obscene is
very very yeah vague word I think I
think antifa's obscene ban them all yeah
they're a lot they're a lot they're
allowed to say their their ideas whether
they're good or bad and um uh they
shouldn't be allowed to advocate for
violence or organize violent defense
which they were doing now that elon's uh
in they're getting banned surprise
surprise child exploitation getting
banned yeah it's really sickening and
crazy what was going on before before
they intervened but I have to wonder at
the same time if this is what we're
seeing now with with Twitter what will
happen to YouTube if they lose not all
of their immunity because this is just
about recommendations do they fall under
the protections what would happen to
them are they going to be able to pick
and choose and play politics that means
Jimmy Kimmel know more you go to the
front page of YouTube No More Mr Beast
no more Jimmy Fallon bye-bye nothing you
gotta search you gotta find it reverse
chronological feed baby yeah it should
be a reverse chronological by default
and I think it should be you should be
able to create your own algorithm mine
says this it's kind of I haven't messed
with it much but you can create your own
what do you want to get fed like do you
like golf do you like dogs hey I got a
crazy idea if you search for someone you
actually find them right you know like
that's whoa yeah that's a big one there
Google I want 10 on that one you and I
think they'll do is they'll start
working minding channels instead of
videos on the front page you'll go to
the front page and it'll say Mr Beast
it'll say and they'll just say these are
these are channels that other people
have liked and they're not promoting any
speech or recommending speech then they
recommend an individual and if the
individual says something well then it's
like well that's their video and that's
we didn't recommend that video so I
think that's the way it might go so
they'll still keep playing dirty we need
hard reform on Section 230. Google
should not be held responsible for the
things that any of us here say but they
should not be allowed to suppress the
content at the same time propping up the
ideas they like suppressing the ideas
they don't like that's weird the idea of
suppression because if two people come
to me and they're like here show
everyone my book I'm like well I have to
pick one the one I choose doesn't mean
I'm suppressing the other guy I just
chose the one no no no no but it turns
out it is a form of suppression I guess
if I'm supposed to be a lot better
that's not what I'm saying I respect the
point that if there's limited space and
they can only show some videos then they
are highlighting videos not suppressing
you if if there's a system where they
say if you get 10 views in 10 minutes
we're going to put you in in the in the
hot new video section and then they go
to you and say except you yeah that's
suppression for sure rules for for
everyone except you you get a special
class of rules that limit what people
can find yeah on Blacklist accounts but
then they're afraid what they're afraid
of is that grandma's going to go to
youtube.com and they're going to see
white nationalism and racism and
militantism and all this stuff they're
like just because it's popular doesn't
mean it's good you know but it might be
the du jour like the thing of the day so
they want to try to curate that front
area for the landing page and that and
that's the challenge imagine if anyone a
man like the the amount of censorship
that we have now imagine if they had
this level of control and speech during
the Civil Rights Movement there'd be no
Civil Rights Movement oh this is
upsetting to people there's protests
it's bad it's aggressive we're gonna
we're gonna silence and shut down you
know they did try they tried stopping
people but people still had
constitutional rights not all of them
were expected were as protected
obviously people had the hard these
rights were hard fought but today
because Communications are happening on
private companies they're eliminating
anyone who speaks out and we're not
talking about the the white nationalists
or the neo-nazis because they should be
condemned totally
now we're talking about people who
believe in free speech anti-war
activists people who want government
reforms people who oppose a taxation
these are people who are getting shut
down yeah anti-war's big because I was
very against the war in Iraq and I was
very vocal about it on YouTube and
YouTube was so down with it they were
like yeah the people at the time were
were also anti-war but that doesn't
always isn't always the case you know in
the Ukraine thing like there's people in
the media that want that they want
conflict over there for somebody they
want like Putin needs to be stopped
Putin needs to be and you're like no
that's the thing if if you do not want
war in World War III like you saw like
Elon Musk like tweet about it then
you're automatically pro-russia it's
like okay maybe we should go to peace
talks or whatever everyone automatically
paints you as pro-russia it's just
insane that's crazy Elon Musk tries
saying hey guys let's not have war and
then all of the votes are like no we
want war
that I think that was a big moment for
him when he was like okay I Gotta Buy
Twitter man
yeah I don't know though but you know to
go back to the starlink stuff it really
sounds like he's planned this for a long
time but I'm glad to see it I'm glad to
see that you know Twitter is starting to
be improved and fixed and uh Michael
Tracy had a really great tweet he was
like these are the rules from 2015. it
just said don't post and threats of
violence or incitement everything else
that's your problem and he was like we
should go back to that Elon Musk said
make sense but it's got to be imminent
threats of violence Elon make sure
there's a time and a date and a specific
thing like someone coming up and be like
I'm gonna kill you that's not an
imminent threat of violence if they say
I'm gonna kill you on a certain day at a
place then you're creating illegal
activities
threats of violence it's legal to do
vague threats it is legal under the U.S
Constitution you know
if it's not if it's not DMS 2 is like
different from like say if you just
tweeted something randomly that like say
it was like a rap lyric or you know
something like that versus like you're
harassing someone in their DMS saying
you know I'm gonna come and harm you I
think what's the difference exactly
um so one is targeted at another person
rather than just on the platform itself
I would say like if you you mean like a
general post this is like at
yeah I think I think DMS should be I
think those are more serious because
that's more personal
um because that's directing it directly
at you and then the other thing is too
with like public officials too they get
like so many mentions I I forget which
elected official uh pointed this out the
other day that they got like they blame
Elon Musk essentially for it they're
like this is what speech is allowed on
your platform the problem is it's not
allowed on the platform they don't tell
people to report it rather than like
this elected official will like
screenshot it and put a tweet up the
question is number one if they felt uh
at risk did they contact law enforcement
number one number two did they even
report that to Twitter so how is Twitter
even going to take that down if they
didn't report it so I think one of the
things that Twitter should be doing too
for all of these people that are
complaining is put put the ball back in
their Court say if you don't want to see
Donald Trump's tweets block him here is
the new feature for mutes because they
have like that mute feature nobody uses
it that's great so yeah so they have um
the hate speech list someone asked they
said what what denotes hate speech and
they said it's not a list I came up with
it's one the company already has why
don't they make that a custom filter on
like the mute button where you can just
toggle that off mute hate speech so the
user gets to choose rather than what he
his philosophy was which like I kind of
disagree with is freedom of speech is
not necessarily freedom of reach thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time